bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques qui n'a pas encore
été suspendus comme le vaccin
d'astrazeneca par monsieur macron
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons parler
du rebond économique de la chine
bonjour astel bonjour olivier bonjour à
tous ravis de vous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro de ses caches comment
l'économie chinoise at elle résisté à la
pandémie de coronavirus l' empire du
milieu est il le grand gagnant de cette
crise ce sont les questions auxquelles
on tentera de répondre dans cette
émission et pour en parler
en deuxième partie nous serons avec
jean-paul chang économiste et
spécialiste de la chine avec 2 3% de
croissance en 2020 et 6 5% au quatrième
trimestre la chine est le seul pays du
g20 à avoir échappé à la récession
si cette croissance est la plus faible
jamais enregistrée par le pays depuis
1976 elle lui permet à tout de même
d'aborder 2021 avec un peu plus de
sérénité que les autres économies
explications avec le tiroir-caisse
d'antoine bassesse
la chine elle va plutôt pas mal en ce
moment d'un an après l'apparition du que
vivent dans le pays
le rebond économique est plus que jamais
présent selon les échos la production
industrielle a rebondi de 35,1 % les
dépenses en investissement de 35 % et
les ventes en détail de 33,8 pour cent
lors des deux premiers mois de l'année
bon faut dire que l'année dernière à la
même période
ces trois indicateurs s'étaient
largement retrouver dans le négatif sur
la croissance a quand même atteint selon
les chiffres officiels c'est important
de le préciser 2,3 pour cent ce qui est
d'assez peu soit dit en passant pour le
pays
nous on aimerait bien avoir ce chiffre
pour ce qui est de 2021
les prévisions tablent quand même sur 8
à 9% de croissance tout ça s'explique
par les usines fonctionnant à nouveau
dès le printemps 2020 puis carrément à
plein bal dès l'été 2020 et oui il
fallait bien les fabriquer ces masques
et autres combinaisons ou respirateurs
pour tous les autres pays prise en étau
par le cos vide
pareil pour l'électronique pour être en
télétravail il en faut alors la chine en
a profité les exportations de matériel
électronique téléphone portable écran
d'ordinateur ou microprocesseurs au
grimpé de 36% en 2020 selon une étude de
gars sociétés d'assurance euler hermes
reliés par le parisien bref la chine a
une nouvelle fois su tirer son épingle
du jeu
et pris l'ascendant économique sur les
autres pays de manière déterminante
voire définitive si les économies de
leurs concurrents ne retrouve pas
meilleure mine très vite
olivier denis auguin froide pour 2 3% de
croissance en 2020 pour la chine pas de
récession après une crise économique
pareil cela signifie t'il que l'économie
chinoise ne risque strictement plus rien
non il faut il faut mettre un bémol sur
ses 2,3 pour cent c'est comme le dit
comme le deal tiroirs cash c'est le
chiffre officiel aujourd'hui il ya des
études qui sont sortis à quelques mois
qui ont analysé les sorties et les
entrées de camions dans les villes et
qui se sont aperçus que la croissance
chinoise était probablement très
inférieure à celle qui était annoncée
pourquoi parce que la récession a déjà
été bien supérieure à celle qui a été
annoncée donc on peut se dire que ce
chiffre de 2 3% et probablement un
chiffre négatif et donc ils sont dans ma
session comme les autres il faut quand
même se dire que la chine est encore
lusine du monde et il le marché
intérieur chinois est quand même très
très faibles donc le vuc ses clients
sont en récession tous et ont une
absence totale de consommation il faut
bien dire que les produits chinois donc
ne sont pas vendus donc vous êtes quand
c'est exactement la même chose quand en
2008 où on nous avait annoncé une forte
croissance de la chine
sauf qu'elle exportait plus rien donc
qui avait il y avait un souci il ya
toujours un souci sur les chiffres
chinois s'est pas ils sont pas devenus
bons s'ils voulaient à cause de la crise
donc voilà maintenant que ce soit le
premier pays à se redresser alors là
pour le coup c'est une certitude
c'est pas nous qui allons tirer le monde
sait bien la chine qui repartira en
premier ça c'est une évidence
maintenant je vous dis vous mettre des
bémols sur les chiffres merci olivier
tout de suite la deuxième partie de
cette émission et cette semaine pour
évoquer le cas de la chine nous sommes
en liaison avec jean-paul chang bonjour
monsieur vous êtes économiste et
spécialiste de la chine merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
bonjour alors monsieur chambon la dir en
première partie un contrairement à de
nombreuses économies majeures du globe
la chine a échappé à la récession en
2020 l'économie chinoise at elle pour
autant tourner un totalement la page duo
qu'ovide faut-il mettre un bémol sur ce
2 3% de croissance en 2020 comme
l'évoqué olivier en première partie
mais je suis un peu plus libéré sur la
critique des statistiques chinoises
parce que si les statistiques chinoises
1 sont entièrement fausses ou on peux
pas la garder confiance dans ce cas là
il y aurait eu une incohérence totale
entre les statistiques du monde entier
cercles de croissance chinois ça se
reflète aussi dans les chiffres des
balances commerciales des autres pays
avec la chine
et puis c'est des statistiques qui sont
utilisées quand même par le fmi et la
banque mondiale depuis toujours je
connais bien l'appareil statistique
chinois et un statisticien de formation
moi même en france je pense qu'il faut
accorder plus de sérieux et aucune
raison ou alors on dit les chiffres sont
pas fiables dans ce cas là de quoi on
parle
ceci dit je vais dire que on peut
toujours dire qu'il ya des jeunes
les marges d'erreur dans les
statistiques ici ou là mais dans
l'ensemble ça ne remet pas en cause par
exemple des réalités dures de l'économie
chinoise
par exemple toit de la consommation pour
tous ceux qui ont travaillé ou bien qu
en chine on se rend bien compte que la
consommation précis qu'en chine depuis
la crise et la relance de 2007-2008 a
pris le pas sur les autres facteurs de
croissance
c'est une réalité incontestable je vais
dire il faut voir le niveau de
consommation atteint aujourd'hui pas les
citadins chinois et urbanisation très
avancé depuis 10 ans 15 ans en chine
pour vraiment admettre ce fait et si on
n'allait pas se fait ça veut dire qu'on
va passer à côté des opportunités de
marché
la chine est en train de devenir le pain
des plus grands marchés de consommation
du monde
cela nous concerne reconnaître cette
réalité c'est défendre nos intérêts et
de faire de bons choix
alors c'est pour ça sur une économie
chinoise elle-même en 2020 il est clair
que les deux premiers mois de l'année on
est catastrophique
il est issu a duré pratiquement jusqu'à
la fin du premier trimestre a eu des
chiffres effectivement qui sont dures un
arrêt physique des activités suite
allait confinement des interdictions de
voyage entre les différents pays à
partir du 2ème 3ème trimestre les choses
ont repris un peu en chine
mais c'est vrai que le ralentissement de
l'économie mondiale des partenaires
chinois
on continue à pas et finalement sur la
croissance chinoise
mais cela dit encore une fois il ya une
continuité de la capacité à la fois des
consommations d'investissement et d'une
façon générale politique chinoise qui a
été interrompue de manière exogènes par
des facteurs exogènes imprévu de
pandémie mais qui effectivement ne pas
vraiment touché mortellement l'ensemble
de l'appareil et que les chinois donc à
une sorte de reprise
certes les chiffres du début de cette
année sont plus impressionnant parce
qu'on part statistiques moins d'une base
très basse
bien sûr ça va sortir après dans
l'ensemble il est clair que l'économie
chinoise est en train de repartir mais
c'est une céline poursuite de ce qui a
été fait avant et le secret de tout ça
aux français ils avaient la capacité à
la fois matérielle administratives et
politiques de maîtrise et la pandémie
qui est la condition sinequanone
finalement pour que l'activité
économique redevienne normale
ce que les autres n'ont pas réussi à
faire partout et à partir de là
effectivement l'économie chinoise donne
l'impression d'être en avance sur les
autres
il faut bien voir que ici en france ou
en europe au même aux états unis
lorsqu'on aura maîtrisé la situation
d'attenté me maîtriser la progression du
virus
grâce à la vaccination par exemple il
est clair que nous allons connaître ou
aussi des chiffres de reprise très
impressionnant alors en novembre dernier
à l'excédent commercial chinois a battu
un record pour s'établir à 75 4 milliard
de dollars selon les chiffres des
douanes chinoises parmi les secteurs qui
s'en sont bien sorties il y a le textile
33% sur un an et des par les masques et
les équipements médicaux aux 42 5% là
aussi sur un an 425 5 milliards d'euros
c'est ce que représentent les échanges
chine eu lieu sur les neuf premiers mois
de 2000 20 ce qui fait de pékin le
premier partenaire commercial de
l'europe des chiffres qui ont contribué
à doper un cette croissance du côté à
des prévisions pour 2021 certains
économistes prévoient 8 à 9% de
croissance au lit fier qu est ce qui
fait que selon vous à l'économie
chinoise a si bien résisté
non mais alors moi je je je persiste et
signe sur les sur les chiffres sur les
chiffres chinois on l'a vu en 2018 on
l'a vu en 2019
on a vu que il y avait un décalage entre
ce qui était annoncé ce qui est ce qu'il
était réellement réalisé alors
maintenant je voulais dit que la chine
soit la première à
repartir c'est une certitude c'est les
premiers à avoir maîtrisé le la pandémie
ils n'ont pas continuer à fermer à
bloquer leurs économies comme l'ont fait
les pays européens dont la france qui je
vous le rappelle va annoncer ou a déjà
annoncé un recond finement pour partiel
donc on sait très bien que les chinois
vont repartir ça c'est une certitude ya
pas deux il n'y a pas de contestation
possible là dessus maintenant sur le
rythme de croissance s'est ya monsieur
le maire qui nous annonce 6% de
croissance en france pour 2021 donc à
tout est possible sur les sur les
prévisions pouvait donner toutes les
prévisions vous voulez maintenant si on
est à re confiné en 2021
en france je vous fiche mon billet que
les 6 % vont s'éloigner très vite et on
sera probablement encore en récession
sur le sur l'année il faut pas penser
que simplement là la vaccination ou
l'arrêt de la pandémie d'une manière ou
d'une autre va provoquer une croissance
délieront pour la bonne et simple raison
que on l'a déjà expliqué ici plusieurs
fois vous avez un potentiel de
croissance pour des pays comme la france
qui est entre 0 et 1 pour des raisons
démographiques pour des raisons de dette
abyssale pour des raisons de
fonctionnement du de la sphère publique
qui pied
or hors de contrôle
vous allez revenir ça et là
qu'est-ce qu'elle avait plus que nous
avant par exemple points on est très
très loin du potentiel de croissance de
2 des 2 rebonds 2 5 2 6 2 7% durable
alors oui vous aurez peut-être une
petite reprise mais ne pensez pas que
dans les pays européens on va avoir une
croissance délirant parce que c'est pas
vrai donc et avec ce qu'on a dépensé
aujourd'hui et ce qui va peser sur nos
économies dans l'est dans les années à
venir on va être loin d'avoir une
croissance important donc ça pèsera
aussi sur nos fournisseurs et dont la
chine
monsieur en europe par mes dossiers aux
états unis à des plans de relance ont
été dégainée qu'en est-il concrètement
en chine
alors c'est la grande différence parce
que je reprends ce que dit holly
effectivement il ya bien un élément qui
est très important c'est que c'est pas
selon la structure de l'économie
investissement consommation etc qui sont
différentes entre l'europe et la chine
les etats-unis la chine mais il ya aussi
la situation financière c'est vrai que
les chinois avaient fait un gigantesque
plan de stimulation économique après la
crise de 2007 2008 et que ça avait
provoqué beaucoup de bulles
donc ils ont tiré leçon de cette
expérience et cette fois ci si vous
voulez ils ont préféré mettre le paquet
sur la règle à 2 du virus et de
retrouver des conditions normales
d'activité économique plutôt que sur des
relances monétaire ou de l'endettement
des états ce qui fait que finalement
aujourd'hui la chine
effectivement se trouve dans une
situation financière ou de finances
publiques est retraite la différence de
l'europe et les états unis et que ces
facteurs là peuvent jouer comme freins à
une reprise match totalement d'accord en
ce qui concerne l'économie européenne
il est clair que européennes et
américaines il est clair que la
croissance chinoise
en quoi il parle ce match on a constaté
sur 2009 à une augmentation de
l'ensemble des exportations de l'union
européenne sur la chine
certes c'est moins de chiffres mais
c'est quand même un pourcentage positif
donc ça veut dire que la consommation
domestique chinoise
représente quand même un marché
potentiel donc un facteur de croissance
potentiel pour nos produits vers la
chine donc ça peut jouer là la reprise
en chine peut jouer un peu nos moteurs
aussi pour la reprise dans d'autres
zones de la du monde
mais si on va marquer une courte pause
en verre dans un instant d emmener dans
ses cages si vous vous rejoignez au
sommaire cette semaine on parle de la
chine et pour cela nous sommes en
liaison avec jean-paul chang économiste
et spécialiste de la chine
olivier l'économie chinoise entre malgré
en fait reprise l'économie chinoise
montre-t-elle encore tout de même des
faiblesses et si oui lesquelles
il ya des faiblesses il ya des
faiblesses structurelles d'abord il ya
un vieillissement de la population qui
est important à cause de la politique de
l'enfant unique pendant des années qui
fait qu' un pays qui vieillit un pays
qui a une démographie qui qui
vieillissante consomme moins on sait on
sait en europe
on sait au japon on sait donc ça c'est
la même chose pour la pour la chine
la deuxième chose c'est un sur
investissement massif qu'on a jamais
connu 1 par rapport au pib
on n'a jamais connu ça etc
c'est un surinvestissement qui
malheureusement a créé des des créances
pourries dans pas mal de banques donc un
taux d'endettement qui a été
exponentielle pendant quelques quelques
années puis une une
une guerre monétaire probable avec avec
les états unis et qui est qui est
intéressante plus que la guerre
commerciale qu'avait déclenchée monsieur
trump qui était un un amuse-bouche
dirait puisque vous avez dit dans une
autre émission que les choses étaient
assez équilibrés alors monsieur byden à
à recommencer une espèce de guerre
commerciale avec huawei et mais c'est
quelque chose d'assez équilibré puisque
savait que les chinois ont calé un quasi
monopole sur tout ce qui était rare
métaux rares ex terra et que donc c'est
c'est aujourd'hui c'est un jeu qui est
compliqué entre les états unis et la
chine
maintenant on sait aussi que les chinois
ont quand même dans l'idée de se dé
dollarisée le plus possible on voit ce
qu'ils font avec les russes depuis
depuis un moment et je pense que la
vraie question elle est là elle est sur
une une guerre monétaire qui a entre
entre les chinois et les américains une
perte de suprématie du dollar qui risque
de ne pas faire plaisir aux états unis
et je pense que la guerre commerciale et
une est l'arbre qui cache la forêt quoi
si vous voulez donc
donc voilà je les les l'espèce de de jeu
pouvoir pour la la la suprématie
mondiale a commencé il ya quelques il ya
quelque temps elle va se continuer sur
les sur les prochaines années et donc
qu'il faut montrer qu'on est les plus
forts et donc je le pense que là pour
l'instant la chine à quelques mètres
d'avancé sur ses poursuivants monsieur
chang vous évoquez tout à l'heure la
consommation intérieure alors selon the
line en économiste indépendant basé à
pékin qui a répondu à nos confrères du
figaro la consommation intérieure est
insuffisant la tendance n'est pas très
bonne depuis cinq ans les revenus des
habitants baisse continuellement par
rapport au revenu et des gouvernements
et des entreprises
est ce que finalement à la consommation
intérieure ce ne serait pas un peu le
talon d'achille de l'économie chinoise
non je ne crois pas parce que je pense
que les inquiétudes là dessus sont
encore par contre le talon d'achille
c'est ce que olivier l'a dit à propos
des créances dans le système financier
dû à des surinvestissements notamment la
bulle qui existent dans le secteur de
l'immobilier alors plus les problèmes
plus structurels plus plus profond du
genre vieillissement de la population
là dessus c'est quand même deux
remarques à faire sur le problème de
vieillissement
depuis 2010 2011
j'ai été en chine régulièrement pour
échanger avec des économistes ou des
décideurs sur ce problème j'ai eu
l'impression enfin il avait conscience
très clairement et de manière explicite
du problème de vieillissement et doit
s'attendre une mesures ont été prises
depuis ce moment là donc je pense qu'ils
vont avoir quelques effets mais donc je
ne suis pas non plus trop catastrophique
quand le par la mesure où le taux de
vieillissement
aujourd'hui l'a7 et chinoise est encore
inférieur à ce qu'on connaît dans
certains pays occidentaux
deuxième chose c'est les problèmes de
l'endettement qui est un problème
sérieux et qu'est ce que ça peut
provoquer en effet notamment que les
créanciers
biliaire des effets domino sur d'autres
secteurs et pourrir le système financier
ayrault met même en question les la
pollution chinoise dans dans la guerre
monétaire dont on parle
olivier tout à l'heure donc le système
financier chinois au talon d'achille
c'est des créances or là dessus c'est
aussi un message qui a été répété depuis
des années par les autorités de suivre
vision monétaire et on s'aperçoit que
l'année dernière par exemple en nous il
va pour la première fois depuis cinq ans
ils ont réussi à maîtriser la croissance
des créances dans le secteur immobilier
c'est le secteur où la croissance ont
cru en mon temps à celui là à taux très
faible par rapport à huit autres
secteurs
deux types de créances cance sur la
conservation créant sur investissement
entre peu immobilier car et c'est donc
ça veut dire qu'il ya quand même un
effort de maîtrise ces problèmes là ce
qui différencie un peu quand même la
chine nous est connu ici c'est que comme
ce n'est pas un système totalement
libérée et qu'elle une planification ce
qui permet de finir allemande est
déterminée détecter des problèmes
relativement en avance et de prendre des
mesures finalement alors le système
politique expliqué peut-être efficacité
de ce type d'intervention qui fait que
malgré tout ça fait comme des années des
années que tous les ans on entend parler
de l'effondrement à venir de l'économie
chinoise et ça ne s'est jamais produit
rapidement avant de se quitter à le
center for economics and business
research estime que la chine deviendra
dès 2028 la première puissance
économique mondiale le pays détrônerait
ans si les états unis cinq ans plus tôt
que ce qui était initialement prévu
l'année dernière peut-on dire que le coc
vide a accéléré la montée de la chine
dans l'économie mondiale ollier alors
savez ce genre de prévisions cck due
qu'à chaque fois on la bonne et simple
raison que aucun prévisionnistes n'est
capable de prévoir la moindre rupture
moi je me souviens d'une dune et uc
avait été publiée par là la bnp
il ya en 2000 donc il ya 20 ans qui nous
expliquait qu'en 2010 la chine se
seraient les maîtres du monde
ce serait une une économie avec un pib
supérieur à aux états unis expérience et
donc si vous voulez il se trouve que en
malheureusement même si la chine avait
fait beaucoup de progrès elle n'était
pas encore passé devant les états unis
bon donc ce genre de prévisions si vous
voulez c'est toujours c'est toujours à
prendre avec des pincettes
alors ce que je vous ai dit je continue
à le dire oui
la chine est une puissance avec laquelle
il va falloir compter de plus en plus
oui la chine est en train de prendre une
place prépondérante oui la chine est en
train de de ne pas paraître en train se
redressera et ira plus vite que les que
les autres ça c'est une certitude
maintenant les prévisions à pour 2028
au lieu de 2030 excusez moi de ne pas y
porter très peu plus d'attention qu'il
ne faut merci et beaucoup jean-paul
chambre d'avoir été parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste et spécialiste de la chine où
les jets nous on passe aux questions
cash
question de patrick ollier quelle est la
différence entre l'inflation publiés par
l'insee tous les mois et l'inflation
l'inflation ressentie par les ménages
il ya une énorme différence en fait
pourquoi parce que pour beaucoup de
raisons si le mode de calcul qu'utilise
l'insee l'insee par exemple va mettre le
la partie immobilière que ce soit le
cathy foulée les les intérêts d'un d'un
emprunt ont très peu proportionnellement
par rapport à la réalité et donc ou coût
réel pour le ménage de d'une location
d'appartement donc c'est faux c'est par
rapport à ça c'est faux c'est aussi
parce que il ya un an une pondération
avec la technologie c'est à dire que
vous avez une voiture avec sans airbag
par exemple et les airbags arrive et la
voiture augmente de 15% et là on va vous
dire ben non elle n'a pas augmenté parce
qu'il ya une technologie en plus qui
fait que en fait c'est le même prix eh
bien non au final vous sortez quand même
15 % de plus pour acheter votre voiture
et vous ne pouvez plus trouvé en fait la
voiture de remplacement est donc ce
système qui consiste sans arrêt à
remplacer un produit avec un produit
moins cher ou supprimer un produit parce
qu'il augmente trop et c'est un fait que
l' indice d'inflation qui est calculé
par l'insee n'a absolument rien à voir
avec la réalité c'est-à-dire vous qui
allez faire vos courses qui vivait qui
avaient des dépenses et qui ne sont pas
comptabilisés dans cet indice de lindsay
donc l' indice de l'insee s'il voulait
c'est un truc totalement théorique il ya
quelques années
on enrayée puisque il y avait le prix de
la balle de tennis comme si tout le
monde s'est acheté des balles de tennis
tous les mois il y avait le prix de la
ban de tennis dans le panier de l'insee
donc c'est pour vous dire que ce chiffre
est tout à fait théorique et n'a
absolument rien à voir avec la réalité
et vous avez une augmentation du coût de
la vie et ça depuis très longtemps on le
voit sur les produits alimentaires on le
voit sur l'essence on le voit sur
beaucoup de choses et ça n'est
absolument pas reflété dans un indice
insee qui est à moins de 2% d'inflation
par an depuis déjà un bon moment donc
cette cette différence fait que
généralement les gens ne comprennent pas
qu'on leur dise qu'il n'y a pas
d'inflation alors que tous les jours
quand ils font leurs courses ils
s'aperçoivent qui en a une et une
importante
merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de votre fidélité
rendez vous sur notre site internet pour
découvrir nos précédentes émissions
et puis pour la semaine prochaine
n'oubliez pas de poser toutes vos
questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux avec le hashtag rtcs h olivier
on se quitte avec votre dernier mot il
ya quelques années pierrefitte écrivait
quand la chine s'éveillera le monde
tremblera
et bien aujourd'hui la chine s'est
éveillée et le monde tremble